[Music]
are you a techno optimist would you
sign up for a trip to mars or a
neurolink
chip to be embedded into your brain so
you can commune with the hazard
and uh like elon musk is having us do
would you would you accept such a chip
implanted into your brain or take a trip
to mars
yeah no i think that i i'd probably i'd
probably do it i mean i i i'm a techno
optimist i i don't think the technology
is particularly
threatening and i think it's enhanced
nearly every facet of human life
what do you think about these kind of
ultimate extensions of that possibly
seeming like science fiction now
so-called simulation hypothesis that
we're actually the result
of a simulation being run on a you know
on a pentium processor
of the year you know 2700 that progress
that you talk about comes with a
downside crispr
gene modification all sorts of things
and in that way techno optimism
uh specifically can cause you know
potentially these dystopian scenarios
but i want to ask you specifically
have you heard of the simulation
hypothesis that we are effectively the
simulation
of this ultimate artificial intelligence
sometime in the future
i've heard the hypothesis there there's
as there's there's
no evidence to back it so far as i'm
aware so it's as much of a faith
statement as a belief in god
with actually i would say maybe
significantly less evidence than the
idea of a
of a guy i mean it is just a form of a
god hypothesis just for in the different
guys it seems
um but i mean given how crappy this year
has been maybe
that's right the simulation has a few
bugs we got to reboot it
i see you as sort of the most uh
optimistic pessimist that i know
uh but what are you really optimistic
about uh what kind of thing gives you
optimism
for the future a human ability to solve
problems
so the thing that we've apparently
forgotten completely about and thus must
take drastic action in order to prevent
uh the the progressive abilities of
human beings to solve problems
you